[Intro music]
Good morning Hank, it's Thursday.
Hank, I can't talk to you with both
my mouth and my hair,
so I'm gonna talk to you with my hair.
Hank, as you can no doubt see,
the puff continues to grow.
Hank, I'd like to thank the yeti
for her endearing support of my hair,
although I have to tell ya',
I think I'm beginning to lose the will.
Enjoy the puff now,
because the next time I see you
I think it's gonna be gone.
In other news,
Hank, I really wanna do
a Question Tuesday on Tuesday,
but I don't really have anything else
I wanna talk about today,
so instead I'm going to include some outtakes
from last week's Question Tuesday.
Nerdfighters, in the next Question Tuesday
I'm going to try to break the world record for
most questions answered in a four-minute period
but I need your help.
Leave your questions in the comments,
and if I don't answer them all in the video
I'll try to answer them in a gigantic blog
post at the ning.
And now: the outtakes.
Take it away, me-from-two-weeks-ago:
"Corn dog meets mint chocolate chip ice cream
in a dark alley - who wins?"
Oh, I'll tell ya' who wins: everybody.
You fry up a corn dog,
you stick it in some semi-melted
mint chocolate chip ice cream,
and you've got the greatest innovation
in deliciousness
since  the deep-fried twinkie.
"What's your favorite graphic novel
of all time?"
There's a lot of great ones, but I'm gonna
go with Maus by Art Spiegelman.
"If you were going on a long trip
to the evil baby orphanage
and could only take two CD's with you,
which would they be?"
A Love Supreme by John Coltrane
and something by the Mountain Goats.
Although honestly, it wouldn't matter,
since evil baby Stalin
is probably just gonna steal my CD's.
"You get to have a one-hour conversation
with a Disney character.
Who would it be?"
Probably Mickey; I'd like to ask him
how it feels
to be single-handedly responsible
for the death
of reasonable American copyright law.
"What's the most interesting
nickname you've ever had?"
One time in high school
I made the mistake of saying that
Christian Slater had never made a bad movie,
and for a long time after that
people called me Kuffs.
"Why do you think that all the most viewed
vlogbrothers videos are by Hank?"
I don't know.
Probably because he's funnier?
Although, in one case,
it seems to be almost entirely
because the screen shot
is of two giraffes having sex.
I don't know what that says
about the Youtube community.
I guess it just says that
"We're people who love giraffes
who love girrafes."
"If you had to pick one pattern
to have all your clothes made out of,
what would it be?"
Definitely argyle.
Honestly, I don't even understand the point
of wearing socks unless they're argyles.
"What's the most embarrassing song
you know all the lyrics to?"
[Speaking poetically]
When I'm not with you,
I lose my mind.
Just give me a sign.
Hit me, baby, one more time.
"If you had to vote for a republican
presidential candidate,
who would it be?"
Definitely Abraham Lincoln.
Oh wait, do you mean like a
living republican presidential candidate?
Well, first-off, I don't vote for the party,
I vote for the individual.
And second-off, I don't want to vote for
any of those guys.
"Why wouldn't you let Maureen Johnson,
who had read your new book Paper Towns,
talk about Paper Towns?"
The same reason I won't let
Hank talk about Paper Towns:
It's secret.
"A plane crashed, and every
single person on board was killed,
but there were still survivors.
How is that possible?"
Every single person on board was killed,
but many married people survived.
Just one of the many benefits.
Oh hey, Riddle, I've got one for you:
What's the only word in the
English language that starts with 'PW'?
"The Iliad or the Odyssey?"
The Odyssey.
"Has Helen Hunt seen The Helen Hunt Song yet?"
No; keep fighting!
"How old is the yeti?"
Twenty-eight.
"Will we ever get to see the yeti?"
I don't know; maybe, if you have a lot of money
and can afford to go on long expeditions to Nepal.
"Which one of the presidential candidates
would you most wanna play Twister with?"
Hmm, that's tough.
I guess Mike Huckabee because, you know,
he doesn't look very flexible, and so I think
I'd have an advantage.
I would wanna play Twister with Ron Paul,
but the problem with that is that
Ron Paul's version of Twister
only has yellow dots
because Ron Paul felt that it would
offer more freedom of choice and also be
less expensive if the game eliminated
the red dots,
the blue dots, and the green dots.
And also the spinner.
And now, Hank, I will be attacked
by Ron Paul's minions.
Don't hate me guys, it was just a Twister joke.
Nerdfighters, as always, thanks for your questions.
Pufflevels? ...I'm gonna miss ya, buddy.